chelsea manning has had quite the
interesting journey
she came into the public eye in 2010 as
a soldier and intelligence analyst for
the us army
after becoming disillusioned with the
war in iraq she intentionally shared
more than seven hundred thousand
government documents with julian assange
who published them on wikileaks it was
the largest single data leak in u.s
history
the documents contained everything from
highly sensitive diplomatic cables that
many believe put u.s lives at risk to
video showing u.s soldiers killing
civilians
she received the longest sentence ever
doled out to a whistleblower 35 years
and after serving seven of those years
she received an unconditional
commutation of her sentence from u.s
president barack obama
depending on who you ask she's either a
traitor or a hero
since then the world has largely gotten
to know chelsea from her witty
observations on social media ranging on
everything from gender rights to
national security but behind the scenes
she's been establishing herself as a
security pro consulting with a number of
privacy focused startups
ironically the network everyone
references as the dark web the one she
used to send classified documents to
wikileaks was actually developed and
largely financially supported by the u.s
government to protect spies and other
government agents operating online
while serving her sentence she had come
up with a better way to cover the tracks
of other online users
over the years the tor network that she
was using had shown signs of
vulnerability there was evidence that
this once
bulletproof technology could be tracked
and the identity that people thought was
being protected was actually exposed
making matters even worse this
technology was largely supported by the
united states government which not
everybody trusts and other western
governments which not everybody trusts
what she had conceived of in prison was
a way to inject what amounts to data
noise
information that doesn't mean anything
into information that does making it
much more difficult to decipher unless
you had the secret code
[Music]
after chelsea was released from prison
um i think just like anyone else in that
situation she spent a lot of time
getting her sea legs so to speak i think
being free was was was difficult for her
um she had actually spent more of her
adult life in prison than she had free
and it wasn't until she was contacted by
harry halpin the ceo of a company that's
building nym network that she started to
really see a way forward to turn her
past experience into a new way to earn
money for herself
people love her tweets she just started
a tick tock
and she was really kind of starting to
go down this path of being
an influencer but when harry contacted
her and asked her for her professional
advice
i think that she and others started to
view her experience in a different way
in particular what she provides is
a very very rare insight into inside the
belly of the beast right once identified
as a very strong patriot um she very
much wanted to protect the lives of her
fellow americans she
leaked the information that she leaked
because she thought it was the best for
uh the country and even though
she's since made a lot of enemies
i think that she still wants to to do
what she thinks is the greater good
the the partnership originally started
very informally harry literally sent her
um an encrypted direct message at like
two o'clock in the morning one night
and chelsea woke up and saw the pitch
as i understand it it was a pretty short
little message but it got her attention
she cleared her schedule the next day
the two of them engaged in some back and
forth he shared the papers that he had
that described his technology she helped
him sort of refine that a little bit by
uh helping him out more as a friend i
think than a business professional
but after a meeting in brooklyn in july
that started to formalize a bit
in fact i was there for part of that
meeting
um and and got to hear them sort of
bounce around some ideas for uh how they
could use um bitcoin to reward
the people that were operating the nodes
that were providing this technology
what we could end up seeing
is
an alternative to tor
that leverages lessons built by one of
the most famous people who ever used tor
but instead of paying for that
with money provided by big businesses
and big governments um there's an
incentive mechanism built into the
actual act of running these nodes that
rewards people with bitcoin
[Music]
it's important to note here there's no
guarantee this works
in fact i asked chelsea directly what's
the biggest obstacle to making this
happen and she laughed and she said
writing the code but it is largely just
an idea um it's an idea that is being
built by harry halpen
who worked with tim berners-lee the
creator of the world wide web
um it's an idea that's being
refined uh in consultation with chelsea
manning one of the most famous users of
tor
but whether or not it actually
does what it sets out to do it remains
to be seen
so the nim network isn't in isolation
there's actually a rising tide of young
startups that are looking to build
alternatives to tor and interestingly a
lot of them are leveraging blockchain
technology past incarnations of this
privacy technology really relied on the
goodwill of governments and big
businesses that thought privacy was good
for them
but what's happening now as a result of
bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies
is
there are companies using new ways to
build business models
that can do the same thing but from a
for-profit perspective instead of
relying on people's goodwill
you